the nfl is gay it is
super duper gay it is liberace level
gay and that is not my opinion well
that is my opinion actually but it uh
what i'm saying is it's not my opinion
uh it is my opinion because the nfl
says that it is true and i'm not i'm not
saying that the nfl
is lame or stupid or well i actually am
saying that the nfl is lame and stupid
but i'm not i'm not using the word gay
to mean lame and stupid like people do
in middle school or anything like that
i'm s i just i want to be very clear i
am saying the nfl is gay
in the narrow sense of men who are
sexually attracted
to men because that's what the national
football league
tells me that it is i've said it for
years
i've said it for years that football is
gay and i know that it's
that seems ambiguous because i could be
referring to soccer
but i also i could be referring to the
nfl and people thought i was
being insulting they thought that i was
i'm not i'm trying to be very
specific and the nfl has just proven me
right
yet again nfl coming out with a very
important commercial
describing itself identifying itself
as gay football is
gay they're right football is lesbian
football is beautiful football is queer
exciting transgender power
bisexual strong freedom american
accepting
everything football is everything and
football is for everyone
the nfl and then at the end here it says
nfl proudly supports trevor project
lgbt youth with at least one accepting
adult have 40 percent lower risk of
attempting suicide go to
thetrevorproject.org
okay first of all
this tactic here at the end
is the tactic of an abusive husband
because what they're saying is
if you do not get on board with pride
month and you do not say that
football is gay and everything is gay
and football is everything
if you do not get on board with that
then you are killing gay people
that's the implication they're saying
that if you do not
get totally on board with pride month
then you are impelling people to kill
themselves
nobody is suggest nobody that i have
ever met
is suggesting that we should be cruel to
people who especially to young people
who have unusual sexual desires
that we should ostracize them that we
should be you know
vicious and mean and nobody is saying
that
but what what this commercial is saying
at the very end here it's almost like a
side point
you're saying if you do not 100 give in
to a very left-wing vision
of sex that includes transgender if you
want
trans the kids i'm going to kill myself
you're going to make me kill myself why
do you make me do this i love you so
much
this is the the language and the
rhetoric of an abuser
and the left is abusing this country and
using all the same manipulative tactics
but zoom out a little bit football is
gay
lesbian proud strong bisexual
transgender
the list goes on and on and on football
is everything
football is not everything
football cannot be everything
nothing can be everything football for
instance is not baseball
football is not an omelet football is
not the number 15.
and this this
error that the left is making is
to erase all distinctions between
everything
you see this obviously in the case of
transgenderism the distinction between
man and woman
you see this obviously in the case of
the redefinition of marriage the
distinction between marriage and
not marriage you see this obviously in
the case of oh gosh i don't know
local state and federal government
that's all blurring together you see
this
obviously in the case of the various
institutions of our government
the various branches of power even the
institutions outside of our government
all kind of blurring together the line
between big tech and the universities
and the government all a little blurry
the left is blurring
all these sorts of distinctions and they
do it with their language
which by the way relates to my book
speechless which is now available for
order it's doing very well in the orders
thank you very much for helping me stick
a finger
at the eye of the uh left wing best
seller list it'd be really fun if we
could
manage to do that we'll see what happens
this is what they want to do they want
to blur the distinction
between all of these things but words
this is why the left focuses on language
so much
words discriminate that is what they do
the very purpose of words is to
distinguish
one thing from another but the nfl says
no
everything is everything there's no
distinction between anything they're
doing it with critical race theory
they're retreating into this position of
nominalism they're saying what is
critical race theory
it's nothing what does that word even
mean words don't mean anything
it's all kind of the same man
come on have a puff that's that is the
error here this is so
much so far beyond the issue of gay
lesbian transgender it's about
everything hey i'm glad you loved that
clip there's a whole episode called
the nfl is gay that's true don't take me
off youtube that she can't be hate
speech because the nfl said it itself
don't don't take me off they're gonna
try to take me off head on over there
subscribe
like leave a comment and most
importantly of all you can order my book
speechless controlling words controlling
lines it's available
now it's now available for order go
check it out today see you next time
[Music]
you